President Vladimir Putin visits Brussels
on january twenty eighth for a summit
focused on the future direction of the
strategic partnership between Russia and
the European Union the summit the 32nd
of its kind will be held in a compact
format with the presidents of the
European Council and Commission the EU
High Representative and russia's Foreign
Minister EU Russia relations have been
going through a challenging period
notably over Ukraine and the union wants
to engage the Russians in a firm and
forward-looking dialogue on the future
of political and economic relations the
talks which will include a short meeting
between the leaders and a working lunch
are likely to focus on the economic
integration plans of both sides in their
shared Eastern European neighborhood
trade issues and key foreign policy
questions like the conflict in Syria and
arounds nuclear program are up for
discussion to the EU with more than 500
million citizens is Russia's biggest
trading partner the talks could also
turn to easing visa requirements for
certain categories of travelers as well
as to European concerns about human
rights and fundamental freedoms in
Russia